madeleine blé moret stéphanie chouinard
a fait jacob bonsoir
quelle journée quand même depuis trois
quatre cinq jours madeleine on le
soulignait où il promet mines est ce que
fait l'écho font les premiers mineurs en
parlant aussi beaucoup de monsieur folle
qu'on avait pas vu aujourd'hui les deux
sortes il a le ton a changé
je vais vous faire écouter monsieur
trudeau
sur la sur la police qui va appliquer
une force proportionnelle on va aller de
plus en plus avec force pour déloger ces
gens là dit on on écoute
une intervention policière qui va être
de plus en plus robuste et on va
continuer de répondre de façon
proportionnée mais la police doit
utiliser les moyens
étape par étape pour en finir on ne veut
jamais
déployé l'armée contre les civils
canadiens une population c'est quelque
chose à éviter à tout prix c'est une
solution de dernier dernier dernier des
rites dernier recours bon je pense qu'on
a compris madeleine que l'option de
l'armée n'est pas en tout cas pas sur la
table pour l'instant moins que ça
dégénère encore plus mais que la police
doit agir oui et ça justin trudeau
l'avait dit depuis le jour où en fait
que ce soit la responsabilité de la
police sauf qu'il n'était pas
nécessairement tout le temps au devant
des caméras il n'était pas là en train
de dire bon on va aider à reprendre la
situation sous contrôle parce que juste
être d'eau n'ont plus le choix de le
faire l'économie du canada est
maintenant affectés par le mouvement des
camionneurs par les manifestants il ya
eu des métastases des ducs on voit un
peu partout au pays et là quand c'est le
lien commercial principal entre le
canada et des états unis qui est touché
c'est sûr que le canada va agir en plus
patrice cet entrain de donner des
arguments au protectionnisme américain
en disant bon bah ça serait peut-être
bien une eau entre nos manufacturiers
d'automobiles reste du côté américain on
l'a entendu de certains élus donc c'est
exactement le genre de sentiment que le
gouvernement canadien essaie de contrer
depuis des années faudrait pas qu'un
convoi de camionneurs viennent tout
bousiller ça d'un coup bon je voulais
faire un tour de table mais pour tous la
clarté de nos discussions je vais tout
de suite vous faire entendre
d'oxford qui est sorti quelques heures
avant qui lui a instauré l'état
d'urgence en ontario pour permettre aux
policiers d'avoir les coudées franches
pour donner des amendes extraordinaire
arrestation facilité et c'est vrai que
ça dure et c'est pour pour essayer
d'apaiser tout son écoute d'oxford qu'on
revient ride with
stéphanie madeleine le souligne
justement c'est vrai que depuis le début
au fédéral on dise son travail policier
mais là la différence et g m2 premier
ministre sont allés devant des caméras
avec un ton qui était très différent de
ce qu'on attendait depuis cinq-six jours
oui oui tout à fait la différence de
reprendre avec le premier ministre ado
c'est que les menaces étaient tout d'un
coup beaucoup plus concrètement on a
parlé des permis de conduire commerciaux
et individuels qui pourrait être révoqué
par le ministère des transports des
amendes jusqu'à 100000 dollars les
arrestations et une peine
d'emprisonnement pour qui pourrait aller
jusqu'à un an donc on voit qu ont durci
le ton de façon significative qu'on
donne des pouvoirs supplémentaires aux
policiers la question qui reste est est
ce que les policiers sur place tant à
windsor car ottawa seront en mesure de
faire appliquer ces nouvelles mesures le
en tout cas une grosse pression pour
qu'ils soient en mesure de le faire
parce qu'on l'a bien compris monsieur
tour doit pas envie d'envoyer du
matériel lourd de l'armée pour pour
faire le travail raphaël une évidence
mais il faut quand même le souligner
c'est rare dans l'histoire le président
américain qui s'est entretenu que
monsieur trudeau aujourd'hui ce matin
lui a dit ça peut pas durer la on se
parle de pression disons qu'il ya peu de
sources de pression plus douloureux du
premier ministre canadien que la maison
blanche aux états unis il faut réaliser
la pression qu'à la maison blanche sans
elle-même de son côté il ya au moins je
sais au moins trois risques énormes
politiquement pour l'installation de
monsieur byden par rapport à toute cette
crise là au canada le premier risque qui
nous sommes peut-être un petit peu loin
de notre perspective c'est que dès le
début pratiquement dès le début de son
administration joe biden a eu à faire
face à une crise à la frontière sud la
crise frontalier avec le mexique ça fait
plus d'un an que ça dure donc imaginer
ne serait ce que d'un point de vue de
perception publique aux etats unis une
administration qui étaient aux prises
simultanément avec des crises évidemment
nature très différente avec ses deux
voisins en même temps ça c'est le
premier problème le premier risque le
deuxième il est évident on en parle
depuis le 30 oc la question économique
on parle d'intégration des deux
économies dans un contexte d'inflation
historique encore les dernières données
du gouvernement américain il ya par
rapport à l'inflation des données
épouvantable plus de 7% par rapport à
l'an dernier donc imaginez l'impact sont
bien empirer les problèmes de chaîne
d'approvisionnement ce que ça peut faire
à la question de l'inflation quand on le
sait et patrice j'ai l'impression de
l'avoir répété presque à chaque semaine
depuis les derniers mois et l'inflation
c'est le problème politique numéro un
pour le président américain est
finalement troisième problème qui
peut-être pas dans l'immédiat mais qui
doit être envisagée présentement de plus
en plus c'est que ça crée une sorte
d'effet d'entraînement et qui en mourant
de la sorte qu'ils prennent naissance et
qui prennent racine aux états unis
présentement avec un taux d'approbation
aussi bas que celui de monsieur bah
était la dernière chose dans la maison
blanche pas besoin c'est qu'on est un
mouvement de contestation de la sorte
qu'ils s'installent en plus aux
etats-unis également oui parce que on
peut regarder des images parce que hier
fox news se passer d'elle buf action
s'est intéressée ou convois canadiens
comme en europe certaines stations hier
fox news channel et et a fait beaucoup
de son émission là dessus et lui pour
lui céder patriote monsieur trudeau est
un pleutre qu'il ya beaucoup trop de
mesures santé au canada donc sans d écho
important à faire exactement et et vous
parlez de fox hier pour avoir regardé la
soirée à la fox pendant un bon bout de
temps t on était pratiquement déjà en
train de faire la promotion d'un
éventuel convoi américain qui sera lancé
le mois prochain donc je vous dis pas
que ça va se produire mais je vous dis
que dans certains gros réseau plus à
droite aux états unis on en parle et on
semble souhaiter que ça se produise ben
justement sur l'échiquier canadien
madeleine et stéphanie on le voit le il
ya des franges d'extrême droite là
dedans c'est une évidence et d'une
frange de droite il ya la fin de semaine
des gens pas nécessairement très
impliqué dans ces mouvements l'homme et
qui en ont marre des mesures sanitaires
donc en fin de semaine il peut avoir un
changement sociologique de la
manifestation mais madeleine il y a puis
on le voit une droite canadienne qui
peut s'organiser de faire des
manifestations qui font mal au pays oui
absolument mais en même temps quand on
vous voyait justin trudeau plus engagé
là aujourd'hui dans son point de presse
moi je le sentais plus engagé mais plus
nuancée aussi parce qu'il ya quand même
des sondages qui montrent qu'une
proportion des canadiens qui sont
favorables aux messages des camionneurs
en fait qu'un sondage des justes cette
semaine qu'ils disent qu'ils ont environ
le tiers des canadiens sont favorables
au message porté par les camionneurs sur
la levée de restrictions liées à la
copie donc justin trudeau qui avait
commencé en parlant des du convoi comme
étant des gens qui portaient
brandissaient des drapeaux raciste
génocidaire s'il y avait dit plus tôt
dans la crise aujourd'hui je le trouvais
plus nuancé en dix ans ce qui est dans
le convoi et qui est tanné de démesure
de l'aco vide sachez qu'on est allés
nous autres aussi donc pour dire bon
vous là on the prairie on vous a compris
et d'une certaine façon ça montrait un
peu plus d'empathie par rapport à ce
mouvement là de gens qui en a juste bien
assez de la coved en disant on va on on
va prendre en considération ce que vous
dites mais aller chez vous là mais c'est
justement de réduire ce qu'on voit là
qui ce qui s'éparpillent et et et grossi
dans certains dans certaines régions du
pays ouais pas stéphanie c'est un
phénomène intéressant il ya des groupes
vraiment d'extrême droit des groupes de
droite organisée qui seront financées
mais qui sont au diapason avec une
opinion publique qui en a vraiment marre
des mesures certains qui donc ça se
mélange touchant oui tout à fait et ce
qu'on al'impression voir actuellement
c'est que le message principal qui était
portée et qui résonne avec une partie
importante de la population comme le
disait madeleine finalement ça a été une
excuse pour certains groupes et
groupuscules d'extrême droit de porter
un message beaucoup plus dérangeant
déstabilisant et qui vise directement
l'état de droit et donc il ou tenter de
faire la part des choses c'était une
corde raide assez difficile sur laquelle
marche les politiciens parce qu'on veut
pas s'aliéner non plus cette partie là
de la population tout en répondant quand
même ou re le bol des citoyens d'ottawa
et du secteur économique autour de
wenzhou répondent aussi comme disait
raphaël ou au cri qui vient de l'autre
côté de la frontière où on se pose la
question si d'investir au canada c'est
au système comprend c'est que ce l'était
c'est aussi une grosse question qui
taraude évidemment d'oxford donc on voit
qu'on tente de faire la part des choses
mais ce noyau dur là il faut quand même
y voir c'est un enjeu important si
monsieur legault au québec n'avait pas
été plus présent dans les médias avec
une crise comme ça à montréal ou québec
dans les deux capitales et des blocages
imaginer je vous fais entendent une
question qui a été posée à monsieur x
est un journaliste qui lui dit samedi
dernier la vous étiez en train de faire
de la motoneige à votre chalet alors
quand avoir été saoul a siégé écouter la
sénateur
veut croire mais non mr bean games fond
de sa
piscine ting tings
mais madeleine et stéphanie rapidement
là dessus quand même il c'était dur
politiquement ce passage là il n'y en a
pas beaucoup vu dix ans maintenant on a
le bon goût beaucoup vu juste un être
doux non plus donc tous les deux sont en
mode rattrapage et je sais pas si
d'oxford était sur son téléphone comme
il dit 24 heures sur 24
mais quand ils ne le communique pas à la
population quand il pas capable de se
passer ce message là ça devient un
problème et c'était le cas aussi pour
justin trudeau qui avait l'air de
vouloir renvoyer la balle que ce soit la
province ou à la ville et lui aussi est
en mode rattrapage aujourd'hui c'est
fini c'est comme si j'étais impuissant
savais pas trop quoi dire et que
d'autres fois ils ne voulaient pas
s'allier et cette opinion publique aussi
qu'on en a assez des mesures sanitaires
on y revient oui il ya eu un jeu de ping
pong juridictionnelle depuis les deux
dernières semaines entre le provincial
et le fédéral est malheureusement
monsieur faut donc ce n'était pas enlevé
plus tôt cette semaine étaient absents
s'il avait été présent à ottawa de la
première journée de la manifestation et
qu'il avait pris une journée pour aller
faire de la motoneige à son chat lire je
pense que ça va beaucoup mieux passé
mais le fait qu'il était tout à fait
absent qu'il y avait un vacuum de
leadership du point du provincial sa
apaiser la population aux rafales aux
états unis la plupart des états ont
laissé tomber la plupart des mesures
sanitaires
même les états démocrate donc le terreau
est pas le même qu'au canada pour avoir
ce genre de mouvements là non plus oui
les camionneurs américains doivent être
vaccinés mais il n'y a pas tant de
mesures une manif est très content quoi
ben justement je dirais que c'est un
petit peu un cadeau dans un sens que le
président a reçu de la part des
tribunaux dans les derniers mois qui ont
en fait bloqué épreuve des grilles de
l'obligation vaccinale parce que imaginé
dans le climat américain sociales et
politiques
ce qu'on aurait pu avoir comme situation
comme dynamique si c'est ce qu'on a
présentement au canada imaginez un
instant donc dans un sens oui le
président s'en est bien sorti un tas ce
qui est important de mentionner sur
l'obligation vaccinale pour que les gens
comprennent louis sur l'obligation
vaccinale des grandes entreprises
monsieur beitenou lève se faire ça il
s'est fait rabrouer par la cour
exactement et donc apprécier son
administration formellement retiré le
décret qu'il voulait implanter avant
même qu'il ait pu être implanté une fois
que ceci dit quelque chose d'important
de mentionner parce qu on est vendredi
et je vous dirais que c'est probablement
été une des plus grosses histoires par
rapport à la pandémie cette semaine aux
etats-unis c'est cette espèce de
cascades absolument spectaculaire d'état
démocrate multiples qui en l'espace de
quelques heures un après l'autre ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient abolir le port
du masque obligatoire c'est important
parce que vous avez absolument raison
patrice à la base les restrictions sont
beaucoup moins nombreuses et beaucoup
moins contraignante aux états unis alors
il y aurait il en reste encore
quelques-uns dans certains états de
façon complètement disproportionné ce
sont dans des états plus démocrate est
justement clairement en voyant levante
on est est bien un gouverneur démocrate
après là haute depuis lundi matin qui
est sorti en disant le masque c'est fini
dans un contexte où je le rappelle à
laquelle se remplit et où seulement la
californie new york l'illinois sont tous
sortis il ya plus que la floride que
l'équipe était caricatural à l'époque
était la seule c'est le contraire très
rapidement ses rangs d'une caricature
pratiquement les états qui ont encore
des obligations de la sorte on en compte
six sur 50 très bien ça m'a fait le
merci on se reparle de l'ukraine à 18h30
au téléjournal
45 secondes madeleine stéphanie est ce
que vous croyez que lundi on va voir des
opérations ou peut-être avant des
opérations policières pour vrai le
madelin bien justin trudeau a dit que ça
irait de façon graduelle alors pour ça
va falloir que ça commence quelque part
et en fin de semaine avec cette
manifestation plus grande qu'on attend à
ottawa je ne sais pas si ça va commencer
déjà cette fin de semaine en fait on n'a
pas beaucoup de détaillants sur les
prochaines étapes merci madelin de
siphonner le pont débloqué à tout le
moins oui une voix débloqué à winter et
pour les policiers je pense qu'on va
vouloir surtout s'assurer que les
enfants et les familles ne soient pas
sur place lorsqu'on commencera à agir de
façon avec plus de force très bon point
parce qu'effectivement il ya eu des
enfants sont amenés dans tout ça très
bien merci beaucoup bonne fin de semaine
à vous trois très intéressant merci
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit